good afternoon my name is john pelletier
i'm a captain with the las vegas
metropolitan police department i oversee
the major violator and narcotics bureau
for those that don't know
fentanyl is a crisis that's plaguing our
society and our community
fentanyl is a powerful synthetic opioid
that is 50 to 100 times more powerful
than morphine or heroin
some drug dealers
make pressed pills which are copycats of
real prescription pills
that look like
feel like and appear to be the genuine
thing
in fact they are killers
and a small amount the size of a granule
of salt
will kill you
let me give you this statistic that you
haven't heard yet it'll be quite
shocking
in 2020
12
children under the age of 18 died from
an overdose
10 of those
were fentanyl related
this year we have five children that
died from overdose
four are fentanyl related
i am here today
joined
by the family members
of 17-year-old
mia
gugino
who died earlier this year
of a fentanyl overdose
on the morning of february 18
2021
mia's father lee
went into her room
found her unresponsive
called for help
medical arrived
and pronounced her dead
they notified
officers who responded
officers observed what they believed to
be indicators of an overdose
and the overdose response team which i
spoke to you about six months ago
responded and did everything they can
to build
the best investigation
to obtain justice
for mia
during
that relentless investigation
the partnership with the clark county
district attorney's office
occurred
and through investigative leads
and measures
we were able to obtain
probable cause for the arrest
of 22-year-old joshua roberts
who was arrested last week
and charged with first-degree
murder
second-degree murder
and sales of controlled substance
as a father
i want to express
my sincere
condolences to mr lee
gugino
and his family
for the loss of their daughter
no arrest
no justice is going to bring mia back
but if it causes people to take a moment
and think about what they're taking
and if we can send that message
to have you second guess and say should
i do this should i take this because it
could kill me
then we've obtained we've achieved
something
and if we can send a message to those
that are perpetrating
in our society and selling drugs realize
this if you sell a drug and it kills
someone we will be relentless in our
investigation to do everything we can to
take you to justice and if that means
charge you for murder so be it
i would now like to turn that over or
turn this over
to mr gogino
uh thank you so much
for
listening to me and listening to who mia
was
and who we lost
for me personally she was everything
she turned me from
just an irresponsible teenager into a
responsible man overnight
by just looking into her eyes and
looking at how much she looked up to me
um it wasn't always easy
uh
six months on in
to raising her i realized i did not want
to work
nights and weekends i wanted to work
days
and
my parents are the type that you don't
have to ask they just invite and i moved
to my parents and we both
started taking on responsibility of mia
i went to school
and to be a teacher like my mom
and my first year teaching was me his
first year in kindergarten
from that point we became an unseparable
duo
doing
the most that a father and daughter
could do
we started
inviting kids after school to play
sports it started with some soccer after
school it grew into hundreds of kids and
then we would play basketball in the
winter track and field in the spring and
swim team and it was never about the
sport or the competing it was all about
making memories
and relationships and friendships and
mia was what made it work she was your
consummate
athlete that you wanted she was not just
a hard worker but she was so kind and
built up teammates
i remember swim team we would have a
hundred swimmers out there that were
brand new
and so scared and the first race was mia
butterfly and she was just so beautiful
and elegant
gliding in and out of the water that you
could just see the kids nervousness just
fall away
and
she would go immediately out and start
grabbing the younger swimmers and
getting them into their spot and they
were looking up to her
the way i do as just this
larger than life goddess
she was so
kind um
she was the unselfish type uh the type
that always was worried about everybody
else if it was a competition and the
other team lost you after 30 minutes
later was
how do you think the goal he's feeling
dead i felt bad when we scored you know
she was that type and i said oh it's
okay man it's okay to
win
but she always saw the other side of it
this girl gave her weeknights and her
weekends to the community that we loved
we had hundreds of teams thousands of
players that were coached by me and mia
the team
she was fearless and she made me um so
much better than i actually am
this drug fentanyl it doesn't give you
any chance
that day
she was herself
playing with her daughter my daughter
our youngest her sister
doing her hair doing her nails
cooking dinner
i went to sleep and i woke up and
everything was gone it was
every day after i go to check my kids to
see are they breathing today
i cry myself through a shower to find
out
a hundred things i could have done
differently that would have changed this
and i
get into my car usually late
and i hear mia's voice telling me relax
daddy relax
i'm a teacher now but it's my first year
without me and i just see her running
around the field that's
the energy i used to put into the
teaching now i want to bring awareness
to this
what's happening
i just really am thankful because so
many people reached out that did not
have a chance and
for us to have some closure to know that
uh this drug dealer is not walking the
streets so many people still have to see
the drug dealer that killed their child
their loved one on the street
and i'm very appreciative to
captain pelletier
detective williams for keeping in
constant contact
it was very important thank you from my
mom and dad
from
mia's sister bella thank you from
her brothers and thank you for me
i
want to say
um
lastly that there was a couple people
that really built mia up to mountaintop
heights and i i wanted to say their
names one the college of southern nevada
coach jocelyn roach
such an amazing person
i gave my daughter a
lifetime opportunity to play for her
community
thank you to her coach andre luciano
with the players who after a devastating
injury saw potential to let her play
again and get her ready for that
uh thank you to
the president of that players
organization for starting a scholarship
for mia
and
now i can continue my father-daughter
work
just in another area
bringing awareness that
this will kill you
she her last search history was what
will ecstasy do to me
this will kill you if we can get
someone to stop and think
live to play another day
thank you for listening to me
i admire mr gugino's courage
and transparency coming before you guys
to share
what has got to be
a canyon of pain
for those that are thinking
contemplating
looking online searching
what are the effects
those that are questioning
what will this pill do to me
i can't say it enough and i can't say it
loudly
for you to hear
one
pill will
kill
if you are even questioning
the authenticity of that pill do not
take it if a doctor or a pharmacist did
not give it to you do not take it do not
buy it from someone on the street and if
you are selling
those drugs realize this if you kill
someone we will do everything and that
includes charge you for murder and send
you away for as long as possible
any questions
sir were there any other
overdoses deaths associated with this
suspect not that we know of
um i
want to extend our condolences to you
and appreciate
your coming forward and sharing your
story
what's the connection between
the suspect and mia and was it that
she thought she was taking an ecstasy
pill and it was really just pressed
fentanyl
so there was a relationship
i have to
allow some of the
investigative process to run itself
through the court and
obviously some of that i give
to you could
sway it a certain way
but there was a relationship and
i would
guess
all the overdoses
that we've seen somebody thought they
were taking something that was not what
they were taking
and i don't mean to
come off that way but if if there was
let's just say a search for
a particular thing maybe that's what you
think you're taking or you're rolling on
mali mdma
and it has fentanyl in it well
you saw the picture the granule amount
that can kill you so
ma'am
it's not something that
occurs every day because there is so
much
investigative
process
and partnership and follow-up that goes
in doing it
when we can do it we will
we year to date
since ort was created we have seven
arrests
on the dealers
we've got another case in the pipeline
but we're going to do everything we can
to do that
so
it is something that we have done
already this year it's something we will
continue to do
until hopefully they get the message and
we don't ever have to do it again but
that's not the case right now
sure there's been a dramatic increase of
fentanyl related that's in the valley it
took a couple of years to catch up to
some other parts of the nation how bad
can this problem get
there's 144 fentanyl deaths
from january to july this year so that's
104 so
get a rim of 144 people and kill them
and i say it that way
because
you can put a thousand people in that
room if you give them fentanyl it's
going to kill him and until people stop
taking
illegal drugs
thinking that it's something else
there it's like playing russian roulette
and it's so deadly
that we've we're here today because
we've got kids dying it does not
discriminate
it doesn't care who you are it'll kill
you it's bad
sir
17 years old so was she able to graduate
high school or was she a senior at the
time
she had graduated early as a junior
yeah in which high school centennial
and you work for the school system as
well what kind of teacher are you
elementary pe
and then she was attending csn
yeah she was a timely citizen
freshman what did she want to be when
she grew older a physical therapist
she had gone through knee surgery and
she liked the idea of helping people
can you tell us about the uniform
i'll let the family do that yeah this
was our team that we created vegas
all-stars and anybody could come out and
play you could see my littlest one eight
and all my other kids three brothers and
my daughters
yeah
and she was the head of the household
nothing went um
not even as small as dinner plan without
her making the call
on it she was just amazing and her
brothers and her sister
she had that unconditional love for them
that was really incredible it smothered
him with love when they walked in all
right guys we're gonna go ahead and wrap
that up appreciate you taking the
message out there
thank you